it's that time of the year for making a
list and
checking it twice and in the case of the
bank of england at the very top of its
checklist for the state of the financial
system is you've guessed it
brexit in 21 days we end the transition
period and of course there's
also possibility of more coveted related
impacts so how well prepared is the
economy
and the plumbing beneath it well the
first thing on the banks list in its
financial stability report
is the state of bank's balance sheets
across the economy the stronger they are
the better their chance of withstanding
a financial crisis and actually look at
this on the basis of the amount of
capital in their balance sheets
they're in quite a good position much
higher than they were before the
financial crisis that red line
there high enough actually to handle a
massive
financial crash 200 billion pounds of
credit losses the unemployment rate up
to 15
house prices down 30 i should say no
one's expecting anything like that to
actually happen
but the bank reckons we could handle it
and over the past years the bank says
they've done an enormous amount of work
to prepare the financial system for
brexit deal or no deal things like
securing temporary permissions and the
recognition regime so businesses can get
finance
from europe but they warned that eu
authorities
haven't done as much to prepare and the
upshot says the bank thinks we should be
prepared for a bumpy ride in the coming
weeks even if the uk gets the deal let's
not forget london
is one of the world's financial centers
you've got money coming in
and going out from europe it thinks
there's a chance some of those flows
might be disrupted which could have a
bearing on currency markets and
share prices as it happens actually the
pound has already fallen
against other currencies in recent weeks
you can see it here versus
the euro that's as investors are trying
to work out
uh the impact of these negotiations
potentially
failing given the pound has been a
pretty good barometer of the saga that's
just people
might be increasingly betting on a no
deal small changes but nonetheless down
the bank says
it's going to do whatever it takes to
maintain financial stability over this
period
what does that mean in practice well
maybe you've got
more swap lines so currency can flow
smoothly into and out of the country
maybe there are going to be other
measures to support the economy in the
new year
much of course depends on whether a
last-minute deal is struck
but even so things says the bank are
gonna get bumpy